this scene the combine scene we call it
this is where uh boat cruise he's had
some ups and downs until this moment and
this is something that Stanley
sugarman's been fighting to get him a
shot at the combine and this is
basically where he gets to show what
he's made up with future Pros people who
are going into the NBA
you against you all right
we've done this a hundred times this is
just another workout
you're an iceberg
Focus kick some ass I love this scene
because it's a culmination stylistically
of all the basketball games that we've
filmed so far and in each game we sort
of add a new technical element you know
in the first game in Spain there's a lot
of handheld in the next game in the five
on five it's a lot of this fast cutting
sort of rhythmic percussive nature of
basketball and then in this we sort of
throw the kitchen sink at it we have the
cameras on the court the broadcast
cameras just like they did in the
Fighter
um we have you know Moby's on um
on rickshaws we have handheld and we
have what we call the Stanley Vision
that's that's the way uh Stanley
Sugarman sees the world the movies
um that really started to inspire me
were boxing movies movies like crazy
Bull and the fighter and I thought it
was so beautiful the way they had
captured that Sport and I thought if we
could shoot basketball like they shot
boxing especially because ultimately it
was mostly a one-on-one game that we
were um that we were filming in the
scenes the scenes were always one-on-one
it was always bow versus Kermit or bow
verse Mr everything so we had this
opportunity to sort of create these
really cool special images that you
hadn't seen before and we did a you know
a long gestating period of research and
then we did this immense test day where
we tested all these different kind of
contraptions
this is exactly
um
as as close as we could make it to what
the real combine looks like although
it's okay yeah
it's in Philadelphia but we had people
come in and set it up so that it was
exact to to the specifications yes yes
you worked hard on that Jeremiah making
it an exact replica and a lot a lot of
the people in the scene are are people
who are part of the combine and they
were nice enough to to give us their
time and make it authentic yeah or
coaches on the Lakers coaches on the
Sixers I think you know okay part of the
team
um opposing teams
yeah government has the Sixers coach
Beau has the Lakers coach yes
yeah and uh Anthony Edwards does a heck
but uh he he gave us his time too and
made it pretty damn authentic too
I thought about my dad a lot as a coach
when I was a kid my dad's name was
Stanley like like my character and um
never worried about anything except how
to make the best of what you have to
offer my father was always just they're
just trying to help me out and that's
how I felt like me and watch his
relationship was it was just true true
love after getting to know Beau Cruz
fall in love with it I just wanted great
things for him and that's how my dad was
for me yeah I think it's beautiful I
mean I think the movie's a father-son
story at its core and you know I think
it's beautiful that you put your
father's name in it either way it worked
he's feeling good
my wife says hi my wife says hello hello
hello they're excited okay I love you I
love you I'm gonna I'm gonna watch the
game this is where I remember when
Anthony Edward started to do this scene
with Beau Cruz this is a beautiful split
diopter shot that Zach pulled out on the
day but I remember Adam leaning over to
me while we were watching that scene and
being like holy [ __ ] it was on the money
it was so on the money when some guy has
your ear on the court and it's just
talking to you and making you feel stuck
you don't want to feel
[Music]
we're off here we go
Focus was doing well he was kind of
ignoring it we built up at the feds
mechanism to block that out but
ultimately yeah it's it gets through
a lot of this theme is carried by um Dan
Deacon score which is a callback Thing
game there's these drums that sort of
these rhythmic drums that sort of power
through the the scene in a really great
and sort of weave the emotion backwards
and forwards and there's these super
hero horns that are kind of layered on
top of it as as Bo start to do well and
then start to fall apart the horns come
down the superhero absolutely yes this
is nice this is basically back and forth
and you're just seeing moments at
Anthony Edward says and then a moments
at watchos on top
you guys shot that perfect man made it
feel so real made it made it you feel
every character what they were going
through and that that is it probably one
of the most painful Parts in the movies
just just because you grow to love boat
crew so much
and then that's it that's that's it for
him that was the Big Show and it and it
was going beautifully and then that was
that one state costume
Anthony has uh juancho's here and
Stanley Sugarman knows something could
go wrong right here he starts to feel it
Twitter
you can see it right there I mean
at the beginning of a beautiful
performance of in this scene that Adam
gives you can start to feel this tension
building
oh okay I see what's going on that's
your mom
as a leader have a kid with your mom
Miss man because we don't really like
that over here
hey I know you hear me hey
one of the things I loved about what you
did during this entire process is you
loved interacting with the real
basketball players and the real coaches
and this interaction here when you and
Greg St Gene is awesome you're like you
feel you're like I can Greg you're
[ __ ] up and just say to say to a real
Coach that you're [ __ ] up is pretty
communicate to each other give my kid a
breather
[Music]
oh yeah yeah right and Greg was great
we're just going like I got this man
just man just stay out stay out of this
and mind your business
Greg take them out give him a rest give
him a rest for a minute we got it you
don't have it
basically it feels like my son out there
and I know what goes on through his head
and nobody knows him as well as I do so
that's why I'm trying to block it but
it's not going to work
I think that's part of what makes it so
exciting the scene is that you're
watching real players and real Coach and
you know you're integrated perfectly
within within the scene absolutely man
and and you just it's so painful because
you know how much talent in in real life
and what the character's Talent has and
you see it slipping away in this moment
that just just costed us one moment
life's Gonna Change for this guy and in
in a way that you don't want it to go
one of the things I love about the movie
is that neither of the characters
neither Stanley or Beau is a perfect
person they're all like they're both
sort of capable of of falling apart and
capable of doing the wrong thing and
capable of making big mistakes and
you're constantly rooting for them the
whole movie not to make those big
mistakes and then in the scene that's
what happens you know he does he makes
that mistake but he pulls it back just
enough just enough to to yeah you know I
remember I remember you shooting that
shot of Anthony on the ground and big
juancho's hand coming an inch away from
his face and then Anthony smiling how
how uh amazing that was that he he knew
we got to old boat
yeah it was a that was a beautiful
beautiful moment
and it's beautiful because you see bow
break at the same time Stanley breaks
and they look at each other they connect
right here right and there's this moment
between them where Kermit is obviously
elated but Stanley is breaking
there's just like one of the first
movies shot
um after the pandemic started we were
working on the script the whole time
during the pandemic of me and Jeremiah
and will were zooming away we were
really focused the shooting process was
different than anything we've ever done
because no one no one was allowed to
touch each other during the first
five six weeks of the shoot right
Jeremiah is that how long it was yeah I
had goggles on and a mask I barely even
saw you
um unless we're in a scene together
working yeah right and and so we did
every interior shot that didn't require
basketball any any body sweat anybody
touching anybody
holding each other so we were particular
this about five weeks worth of stuff we
could shoot we shot that
worked on that right you you edited we
we
um then we we came back what like eight
months later or something
one cool thing is it allowed us time to
storyboard the whole movie and animatic
the whole movie so we were able to
automatic all the scenes all the
basketball scenes all the phones we knew
the edit intimately when we went into
the second part of the um yes that's
true which was really helpful and fun I
was able to refer to that every time I
uh I opened a day I was able to look at
my storyboards and say this is what I
need to get
um and then you know for the basketball
especially that was helpful because the
basketball scenes were so detail
oriented favors I'm not asking for a
favor this guy can play
everybody keeps saying that that but you
don't know the whole story
he's meet the kid what was
cool for me filming this scene it was it
was um it was in the first round of
shooting and it was really quiet we made
the set really quiet and I got my chance
you know because we didn't have a ton of
interaction to watch Adam prepare for
the scene
um and he sat there with Coach Bobby uh
Bobby verton and and he sort of went
over all these
you know uh ideas that weren't writ
scripted things that were that were you
know part of the real combine part of
the real world part of
the real life of what coaches experience
um and and we did the scene over and
over again and Adam would just Riff on
those ideas and those ideas are what
makes it I mean those lines are in the
movie they're they're not scripted lines
they're ones that Adam sort of brought
out of his belly and sort of threw onto
the screen it was in the moment
um and uh I think that's what that's
what keeps the movie so alive you know
that that Adam is constantly
you know putting himself you know
verbally and emotionally into the scene
you know his whole self and and and and
I think you know maybe I'm wrong Adam
but I think also you're putting part of
your history into the scene I mean I
think that part of who you are yeah
maybe yeah yes me some of me some of
people I know some of uh you know uh I I
grew up playing basketball I grew up
knowing these guys I also grew up in in
Show Business and have seen people not
get uh what you know give give and give
and not get anything back and the pain
they feel and it's connected a lot of
different things in my life and maybe
some stuff from my real life yeah
we'd start the scene with Jordan and
from her perspective and I sort of
thought of it like the scene in
Rosemary's Baby where you're watching
John cassavetes on the phone and you're
constantly trying to see him you can't
see his face and that was sort of the
beginning of this thing like what is
happening to this guy what's happening
to him I need to see him I need to see
him I need to see him so the whole scene
starts there from her and her feeling
and her need to see because that's what
she is she's a watcher then you're in
his experience for the rest of the scene
I think that's it's so moving to to go
you know to be so far away and then
suddenly so close God damn it I I spoke
at your father's camp
every year and I never asked for
anything back okay so I'm asking you now
for something please help me
watching Adam explode is a beautiful
thing and then you don't realize that
Queen Thief has been watching him the
whole time kind of the most moving
things like all of a sudden she's she's
there you know there's your wife like
the only person you can be vulnerable in
front of the only person you feel
comfortable being a vulnerable in front
of and the whole time she's watching and
she's saying this line that he says to
her over and over again you know to
provide comfort and in this case it
provides no Comfort there's nothing that
can comfort him family is is not about
play it's about the next one right
that's if you're in the game T I wasn't
even in the game
you finished with the daughter's
perspective so you know you're reminded
that you know this will affect her as
much as as it affects them I thought
this scene was electric when we were
shooting it it was like it was like this
thing where you could you felt this
thing okay I think Queen Latifah Queen
Latifah came up to me after like the
fourth take and she was like I can't do
that again it's too painful this is too
bad yeah yeah yeah I remember that yes
I'm sorry we have to do it again that's
right that is the craziest part of
making a movie is is feeling it going
for it and then saying okay we gotta
create that every angle let's keep going
man